hi it's uh Luca from the polygon green
and I'm here with Timothy donor for
those who don't know - method owner is a
super golf polyglot he's a teenager
super polyglot and a lot of people in
the community learning community knowing
hi hi Tim how you doing I'm doing great
Lee Barry oh I'm doing great the weather
here in Versailles is absolutely
fantastic so I'm in a great mood and I
hope that the weather is great in New
York as well okay now I have a few
questions for you Tim the first one is
going to be on about you're interesting
in that in languages so the very first
question is how can you speak so many
languages at your age what's the story
behind it's a lot it's a lot I know it's
a complicated questions a little bit big
but try to make it short but yeah sure
okay um I guess again it all it all
comes down to practice and exposure you
know the same way you you need people
like yourself or like Richard who who
can speak or can switch through ten
languages seemingly without effort just
because you've been exposed to them so
much and you got to practice them so
much for me it's very much the same case
I mean I haven't I haven't spent that
much time abroad with foreign languages
but I really think it just comes down to
whatever is flowing in and out of my
head on a daily basis and at this point
I mean for example I do get to speak
maybe between eight to sometimes ten or
more languages a day and I guess because
of that they all they all have a very
distinct I guess personality so to speak
or to sing story to them that keeps them
separate from the other ones okay um I
know this stone has been turned over so
many times how many languages do you
speak at the moment you know we we had a
discussion about speaking the term
speaking but you know the language you
feel comfortable with when you have a
conversation with a native speaker in
general right um you know I mean I went
here and say that I speak English okay
there was matter what is definite I
would put that one down as a language I
speak I mean besides that I to be honest
I mean I've studied I studied more than
20 languages point
I'm comfortable in most of them um but I
guess I guess I mean I certainly can
have a conversation at each but I mean
the question is you know how would good
a level of a conversation so for that I
would say you know maybe I have five or
six main ones that I'm very very
comfortable in another ten that I am
comfortable in to various levels you
know and I can have a relatively good
conversation and then you know another
five or six that I'm still a true
beginner Adam really kind of working at
to that degree okay so I won't make you
learn these languages especially with
less than once you know well I think um
I've always had a big interest in
history and political science so I think
I think each language exposes a
different layer of history that you
really weren't familiar with before I
know they wouldn't know in you know in
any other event what I think is
particularly interesting is that you
look at you look at places very far
removed from the indo-european world um
and by that I mean especially the
Islamic world and you see that all these
languages that have kind of interacted
with each other you find I mean Arabic
has had an influence on everything from
Wolof in West Africa - you know
Indonesian all the way in Southeast Asia
and you find you find influence of
Persian everywhere and find kind of kind
of a cultural hybrid with each language
and that in particular really interests
me and then and besides that for other
kind of less common languages a lot of
times it just comes down to you know I
love picking up new ones or just
learning different ways of
conceptualizing the world um so for
example when I I started learning our
jib way I found it in a linguistics
textbook and it just seems something
that was so bizarre and removed from
anything I'd learned before so I decided
to pick it up her to try and dig it up
and that that kind of replicates itself
very often there's no there's no real
motivation in terms of having to
communicate with people it's just it's
something that really stands out very
interesting until okay let's talk about
okay the first one so the first topic
was you're interested in foreign
language in general so now let's move on
to the method your methodology to our
languages to acquire languages you're
you know as I told you you were sighs
you're an encouragement for so many
people learning foreign languages I just
can you please tell us a little bit
about your study habits you mean how
where do you start from what what do you
do what is the bare first thing that you
do and you have a fixed routine or
plan that you usually follow or how does
it work you know very interesting in the
very first thing that you do whether
independent language maybe changes
depending on the language tell can you
please tell us a little bit about that
absolutely so the first thing it
generally depends if I you know when I
started picking up German whatever I was
a month ago or six weeks ago I decided I
really wanted to learn it as a language
I would be using and communicating with
a lot so the very first thing I did was
I bought a German textbook with a CD
very traditional way of doing things
actually I guess and I did the first six
lessons um and I mean after that I found
that I did find that even if it was a
very basic vocabulary I hadn't enough
flowing in my mind to start making
sentences and trying to translate
everything I could on on like a second
to second basis so not only for example
what I have those lessons like you know
buying things or counting through ten or
whatever it was but I would try to use
that and employ it just an everyday
usage so what happened after that
was that once you have a basic
vocabulary of let's say 100 words or 200
words and some understanding of the
tense system if there is one um and and
basic grammatical constructions which
you can do then is that you need to
expose yourself to the language because
you're not in a foreign environment so
the only way of doing it is trying to
communicate in it at least in yourself
as often as possible so what happens to
me after that is that I said anytime I
don't know a word um it's part of the
learning process you you look it up and
I find at least that from context it's
much much easier to remember later on
because I think oh you know how do I
know the word for let's say
controversial in German which is
pollution sentence and remember that
because I was reading an article on on
the classification of Japanese I'm in
Albania and it was for said that it was
part of the Altaic family getting stupid
little little things like that and it
makes the word stay in your head okay
I'm just going on and listening to a lot
because you just you just look for a
base in language you get the basics and
language and you try you looking forward
to being able to use that you know a few
words you talk to yourself like at the
beginning your you talk to yourself in
the shower for example if I do sometimes
not even a shower just in
everyday life was very embarrassed
actually so okay I got wait wait a
second this is pretty interesting cuz I
I heard another probably would say that
he wasn't on the bus he was try to talk
for himself or repeat things when he was
reading a book and people looked at him
a little bit quizzical II and we asked
himself asking themselves what is he
doing but you know so it did happen to
you didn't occur to you that you talk to
yourself you know in front of other
people because they were trying to
concentrate you were trying to you know
just train your oral abilities not only
in shower as I said I've haven't
happened to be doing during tests even
everything cuz I don't even I just
wanted out even realize that it's been
expensive just a physical habitat mine
for the last three years um
trust me I completely understand thank
you is that a lot of my language
learning also comes from song lyrics um
like especially when I when I started
learning Hebrew which is a first foreign
language that I really did I just
memorized hundreds and hundreds of
different songs and they would be
playing in my head on non-stop and I
used to kind of sink in myself in the
middle of the day just in class and in
the subway and if I mean it definitely
kind of immersed the language in my mind
even if I embarrass myself so and then
okay so you think some people might find
it weird I you know at the beginning I
tried to do it I want to take a shower
for example in my media it's it's a
little weird but I try to focus a little
bit when I these moments where I take a
shower I go jogging sometimes you know
and I think it sticks your head is so
you think that the the fact that you're
actually getting something out there
with your mouth helps you remember that
right so for example you learn 100 words
and then you try to do you try to form
phrases with those words and with verbs
you know you got 100 now sort of an out
100
no thanks and then you use you have a
list of basic verbs what do you do with
verbs do you look for the most basic
verbs the most common verbs and then you
try to use them actually I used to do
that I had I had a list of 10 verbs
things like to see to eat to go etc um
which I still do but at this point
actually what I find is that once I have
a basic enough vocabulary what I'll
actually do is I'll take a look at an
article in the language I'll take a look
at a basic book inner language and then
by that kind of exposure that's how my
vocabulary comes up so as I mentioned
for example I I read Wikipedia and
German the lot I try to read an article
every day just for just to kind of keep
it up and to build up my vocabulary and
it's really from that that I've built up
like the verbs that I know so then I
know obviously at this point all the
basic ones but also more complicated or
more esoteric ones which I won't
necessarily use but that's kind of the
that's the language that I pick up it's
the more kind of academic or scientific
version as opposed to the more touristy
set of words that make sense yeah yeah
it does it does that add up now okay we
talked about your method more or less so
you know about activating the language
and stuff what about the materials for
example what resources what resources
you use or preferred using which
materials would be perfect you know for
you like books with many dialogues via
grammar explanations come audio files
etc because I got my own preferences you
know like ask Simone and stuff Ryle is
wondering about yours iso by the way is
fantastic and no idea why i need to know
about at report on your parrot because
his sides actually it's pretty popular
in in the in europe but not as popular
in the united states for of course on
gala it is alright because I'm French
mostly but um yeah I mean I've been
using I've been using a Sanel to do to
be he - recently which actions been
quite a lot of fun um besides that I
would say a lot of times for speaking
practice or just getting a very very
basic level would be Pimsleur mm-hmm
full conversation a lot of people have
problems with it but I actually like it
and it's a good way to pass the time in
the mornings
besides that I what I generally tend to
do is I buy um some sort of workbook and
I I mean I I know this is just me and a
lot of people don't like this I almost
make it harder for myself by by making
sure I study the grammar and I break
that everything down in that way because
what interests me is a communication as
a second point but we're really
interesting is the structure of it I
mean the actual linguistic typology that
relates to that language so for that
reason I like to do exercises and I love
having dialogues but it's always very
interesting to break those down and see
how they work and then see what other
you know pieces of language you can make
out of them
besides that there's a lot of audio
files music but in general it's just
it's just a speed constant 24/7 exposure
so really it's just anything that's on
the internet YouTube bloggers newspapers
music whatever whatever comes to mind I
was just wondering if you know you use a
combination of materials because as far
as I'm concerned is you know when
starting a language is the very first
thing that I do is use a simmer or now I
just use a so modality truth so I am
greatest and then I use other resources
when I get to intermediate level and
stuff but I was wondering if you know a
wise combination of materials could be
useful for example you don't like uh you
know weeding or just you just want to
listen as you did Pimsleur is pretty
good then in the afternoon you can do
something else I like what you said
about mixing things you know finding the
best parts of each program that worked
for you and that's definitely true in my
case
Pimsleur really does not mean I found I
found that for example when I when I
started doing Dutch I started Dutch just
with Pimsleur and I'd never take a look
at the written language and then when I
finally did I absolutely no idea how to
read it okay yeah yes all right
I make no sense to me I mean so for that
I think it's interesting to have a
combination let say Pimsleur SML teach
yourself I mean whatever works really
yeah and then you can add you know the
wheelstop on the internet and soon as
you programs in the language yeah okay
no we talked about the materials we
talked about the method and we talked
about your interest in languages now I
was wondering you ready
maybe in part you already answered this
question about vocabulary how you primer
Kevlar so the first question would be I
heard you know I heard you say that
usually learn a huge amount of
vocabulary in a very short time so I was
wondering why is your to keep for doing
it you learned the main from context as
you said we're also making your own
lists from words you like lists I love
lists okay so tell me how you go about
it
well I think in general I I tend to use
a copious amount flashcards um I mean
it's a very rudimentary thing but it is
quite effective
um and I mean anytime I have free time
just in general like I have a lot of
flashcard apps on my phone and I'll just
scroll through them and you know maybe
and a lot of these a plate they quiz you
on another quiz you in reading writing
and speaking so I think it's really just
from that very very repetitive but
useful process that you begin picking up
vocabulary and at least for me I find
that especially in those sorts of
contexts I tend not to forget them again
it really helps building vocabulary if
you listen to music a lot a memory song
lyrics or if you there's a certain book
that you're really interested in and you
you're reading with a dictionary or
something like that that will help you
inordinately but I think in addition to
that you can also take the traditional
approach and I like to combine them
mm-hmm that's great and what about
grammar
what is your repeat on studying grammar
do you think it is important to
deliberately consider grammar rules
right from the beginning or is it a
hindrance at the beginning when you find
a helpful the others saw as you know I
wrote an article about that and there's
a lot of people would take that grammar
you know you have to use grammar books
you're going to learn language you infer
grammar rules from the language for
constant exposure so what's what's your
take on it I think you do different we
had a discussion when you do anywhere in
Paris you said that you like grammar you
like deciphering grammar and gentle as
it were a code what do you do I be quite
honest I really I have to say um you
know for someone
learning a language for - like tourist
purposes or just you know communication
and you don't really have to learn
grammar I mean I quite honestly I think
it's M some ways as I said before I make
it almost hard hard for myself by
studying extra but it is what interests
me and I think you know definitely if
you may people language class let's say
you're trying to teach someone Hindi for
example is the first thing you're going
to do - you know explain what split
burger tivity is no probably not have
people staring with their jaws open
we're going to run out of that class as
soon as they get the opportunity I think
you know in general for me studying
grammar is it's an interest because I I
see all language fundamentally just more
or less as a code that can be broken
down and once you have those individual
puzzle pieces you you kind of have the
key to saying anything else obviously
you know if you're if you're living in a
foreign environment it's very very
different or if you're if you're missing
like Kinsler it's very different because
that's just causing exposure so you know
well I don't know this is the ablative
case but I know that this is the way the
word sounds when I put it in front of
this preposition and that's the way that
all humans developed language for me
however because I'm kind of you know
doing this from the sort of solitary
confinement of books it's it's a more
it's a way of keeping the language
interesting for me and kind of keeping
it fresh in my mind but in addition to
that there are there are a lot of
benefits about you know learning the
grammar and obviously people understand
you no matter how how badly which are
the grammar as long as you kind of have
a good sense of what you're saying but I
think you know in general it definitely
does have its benefits at least for me
when I'm speaking a language I'm
constantly flipping through about
grammar mm-hmm okay no as far as
speaking is concerned people are amazed
by the fact that you start speaking in
language in a matter of weeks what you
do actually to acquire speaking fluency
in such a short time a special train
techniques like shadowing go to
materials softener native speakers from
day one or what do you do exactly
or those yeah I mean I think I'm living
in New York I haven't had the
opportunity to kind of practice a lot of
languages that you wouldn't necessarily
get to practice in a lot of other places
so on any given weekend I can go out and
I can speak Chinese or Bengali or candy
or Wolof even I mean I
you know that's certainly very very
helpful for me and a lot of times these
people are very receptive to having
foreigners speak their language so
that's definitely a plus in terms of
practicing and also I would say just
going through an internal monologue and
talking to myself 24/7 certainly keeps
the language fresh in my mind and it
almost gives me a cheat sheet when I'm
speaking I've been through so many fake
conversations in my mind but by the
point I start talking to someone they're
really only so many things that they're
going to say to me and at that point I
really just feel like I can pull out
phrases that are I've already been in my
head for weeks and make a conversation
out of that and then in addition to that
I think a lot of it is just it's just
about confidence you know I think even
if you not you're not very good at a
language if you're talking to a native
speaker and you have a relatively good
pace of speech and and you know you
throw in vocabulary words that aren't so
common they're going to be a lot more
relaxed around you and that might make
it a more interesting language
experience so it's the combination of
all those things I think it's very
interesting the answer just deep so do
you think in confidence pretty important
I find it as well because you know I
think confidence is one of the most
important things in language learning I
know people who can actually know the
language but they don't have confidence
in themselves and that and thus you know
the result is much more than it actually
in their actual possibilities so you
think so basically what you're saying is
that you mentally you train yourself all
the time if you're constantly thinking
in the language and then you are
confident right absolutely that's a
great answer like it's simple and to the
point and let's talk about accent you
know I like accent and pronunciation
intonation and stuff you have received
many positive comments about your accent
in some of the languages that you speak
on YouTube do you devote any special
attention to it or have a particular
technique for getting it closer to
native speakers for what do you do do
you care about accents you were I don't
already discuss that a matter interview
but I just wanted to know louver more in
detail what what do you think about the
story um so yeah as for accent I would
say in general I don't pay as much
attention to it because I'm more
interested in language from a linguistic
perspective but of course it is
important and you know they're having a
lot of times where I've butchered it
especially in Russia Russian and a
member of other languages and again I
think that just comes with constant
exposure I would say I mean probably I'm
most comfortable speaking in French
because I've had I've actually spent
time in France and I have to speak it on
a daily basis but for languages with
less practice then
yeah accent is certainly a problem but I
would say I mean in general growing up
in New York especially again you get so
much exposure to people speaking English
with different accents that it's almost
it's very very common to hear English
spoken as the second language crafts
needs more compliment dear and as a
second language than is steered as a
first language um so for that reason I
think you we're exposed from a very
young age to all kinds of into nations
and pitches and that inadvertently kind
of influences the way that we speak or
we kind of impersonate other people and
when I was younger actually used to
radio commercials so I yeah we used to
at least have an ear for accents if it's
going out so much anymore but I think
again I mean if you if you really want
to do it all it takes us is a lot of
dedication and practice and listening
okay okay so we just touched on very
general topic so I want to you know end
the interview here but I just wanted to
tell you that okay this one was in
English for those who are wondering
because Timothy and I speak a certain
number of languages but I just wanted to
propose if you want you can ask in the
box below you know YouTube box if you
can ask some questions and we will
answer a selection of the most
interesting ones we will discuss them in
death and in other languages to make the
you know the conversation even more
interesting so the next video is going
to be a you know we will be answering
and discussing some of your questions so
thank you Tim for being here for the end
for the interview and I'm going to talk
to you very soon
great to talk to you bye bye